[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof hello martin
hello walter how are you doing i am very
well in you no i'm fine thank you
so what are we doing today
well we're going to talk about the
economy of francesco
which happens to fit into
a pattern of a new world order
which happens to disprove the fact
that it is no longer a conspiracy theory
ah i like that let's open with a word of
prayer
our heavenly father we thank you once
again
for bringing us together in having a
discussion about
most important things we ask that you
bless us and enlighten our minds with
the holy spirit and we thank you in
jesus name amen amen
you know martin that people said
we're going back to normal
once
everything is over with the
pandemic
and
we were of the opinion that this is the
beginning of the great slide
yes yes but maybe we misunderstood it
because they did say it's the new normal
yes and they did say it was a reset but
we said it would be the great slide to
petition exactly
so you know martin
we always try
to correlate world events
with the biblical picture
and the biblical picture is so sublime
so we need to do that again we need to
just orientate our minds as to
where we are in the stream of time yeah
and what's happening is something's
happening here something's happening
here and there
and it's
it looks disjointed it looks just
jointed but
everything links back together and then
the bible is the catalyst that you use
to see how all of this fits
into
it's like the blueprint right
yes
so the title the full title of our talk
today is the economy of francesco part
one
and the results of the war
not the results of war no because
there's a specific war going on right
now and the timing of that specific war
is very interesting
because it comes immediately after
a health crisis on this planet
and
this war
exposes
if we can put that in very strong
inverted commas
economic problems
financial problems in particular
supply line problems
and everything else that has to be
rectified if you want to reset the
world's economic
social
religious order that's it if you want to
have a new order
this is the perfect
scenario
yes
but
let's take this good book
and let's turn to revelation
chapter 11.
now revelation chapter 11 is a very
fascinating chapter
it sets the tone
for the events in the heart of the book
of revelation
so in chapter 10 we had the unsealing
of the sealed scroll
which of course is a reference to daniel
because that's the only sealed scroll in
the bible and we have to be consistent
right
so in other words the unsealing of the
scroll which would open our
understanding to the prophetic events
in the last
days then revelation chapter 11 before i
say that
the last days
the time of the end
now according to daniel the time of the
end it begins at the close of the
1260 days
which was in
1798 right
now what happened in 1798 in 1798
the beast received a mortal wound
in other words it lost its political
stature and that's what happened
when
rome lost its political power the papal
states were taken away
it was turned into secular states the
pope was taken captive
and it seemed as if the political power
we're not talking about the religious
power we're talking about the political
power was at an end
but we learned in the book of revelation
that that power would be restored
and that it would take a while
it would take a while to restore this
power
but eventually as it was in the middle
ages when the kingdoms of the world gave
their power unto the beast
when the restoration is complete the
kingdoms will again give their power
unto the beast
now before that can be achieved there is
first some underground activity
now when you go to revelation chapter 11
we actually read about a conflict
between this power
and god's word
we're not going to do a study on
revelation chapter 11 now we're just
going to lift out some of
these highlights
so there is a a war
basically against the word of god
in revelation chapter 11
and a new philosophy is introduced into
the world the philosophy of the french
revolution which promises liberty from
all kinds of oppression
and it also promises fraternity isn't
that interesting brotherly love
brotherly love so in other words what
happens here
is a philosophy
which is embodied in a political system
a beast
will eventually
permeate the whole world
and will finally culminate in the kings
of the world giving their power unto the
beast
so when we read here
this war against god's word
will culminate in god's word basically
being eradicated but then it will have a
resurrection
and everybody who will have an
opportunity to study god's word so the
great bible societies were formed also
in this period and the word of god went
out into the world but this power that
is the enemy of god is working in
darkness
now we read from
verse 7
and when they have finished their
testimony those are the two witnesses
that represent the old and the new
testament
the beast
that ascends out of the bottomless pit
shall make war against them and overcome
them and kill them
in other words there's a war against
god's word
and this war is driven by a power which
is a beast which represents a political
system which ascends out of the
bottomless pit
that's the abuse
or let's put it this way it could also
be
the grave
so this power that had received the
mortal wound
has a resurrection
and it with its philosophy
makes war against
god's people
and against god's word and as we have
seen in the previous two what's up prof
that attack on the word
is also
infiltrating and changing the true word
it is a
if i can use that terminology total
onslaught yeah
that's what it is
in any case
once this beast has arisen
with its
philosophy
and basically
in darkness conquers the world's
thinking
and infuses the world with its
philosophy
then we are introduced in chapter 12
to
the
the power that it comes into conflict
with
namely that power
which represents god namely god's church
so it gives us a brief history of god's
church through the ages even the time
when they prophesied in sackcloth
during the 1260
days or years of papal suppression
and then it tells us that finally there
will be a conflict
between these powers of evil that are
basically
nurtured by the dragon
and verse 17 tells us and the dragon was
wroth with the woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
her seed
which keep the commandments of god and
have the testimony of jesus so that's
god's people right
so we've had the rise of this philosophy
culminated in a political system
now rome received its political power
back in 1929
when mussolini
returned a small
symbolic portion of the papal states
right
and then in revelation chapter 13
we read about the history of
this beast and what it did that it
persecuted the saints and what it looked
like and it's basically
a
conglomerate rewrite of daniel chapter
that's it seven it doesn't have complete
political power
because the kingdoms of the world
haven't returned that power into it
but it's working in darkness
so this beast that arose out of the
bottomless pit so it tells us about the
history but it has a representative
that speaks on its behalf
so that it appears as if it is not he
but in actual fact it is behind the
scenes
and that is the second beast of
revelation chapter 13 right
so that second beast does on behalf of
the first beast everything that the
first beast was able to do quite openly
before it received the mortal wound
so it tells us
in this dramatic story
about
this particular enemy of god
and it once was
and then it had a mortal wound and it
was not or appeared to be
not it appeared to have a mortal wound
revelation says it didn't have one
really it's a counterfeit wound but it
appeared to have one
and that is a is not stage and then it
rises up
and it is again a is stage
now in revelation chapter 14
we read about the conflict
between this woman of revelation chapter
12 the true church of god and finally
the remnant
and the system
and what the final message of warning is
and the three angels messages are in
chapter
14 right
and then
the result of that we will read about in
chapters 15
and 16
what happens at the end of that message
the plagues fall etc
and then we go into an eschatological
section
now we said in a previous study that the
book of revelation
is written in a chiastic structure so
often the things are in reverse
so revelation 17 and 18
look out of sync because things happen
in 17
whereas 18 actually precedes what
happened there so we must take that into
account but we don't want to do a full
study
we want to concentrate
in this particular study
on what happened in revelation chapter
17.
now in this
study
the revelator is shown the great
judgment of the great hall
and it tells us that this system
this prostitute system that also happens
to be a beast or a political power
is actually
the leading power of babylon
so in verse 5 we read an upon a foreign
was a name written
mystery
babylon the great the mother of harlots
and abominations of the earth
so she's the mother of all the harlots
and collectively
they are called babylon
now a harlot or a
woman of disrepute
is a church or a religious system
that is in apostasy as far as god is
concerned but she's the mother of them
all
so that tells us that in any council
whether it be economical or religious
unity of any kind
there will be a mother figure
and that is also a beast figure because
it is also a political figure
so that is how they are joined together
and it tells us some details about this
woman that she was drunk with the blood
of the saints takes us back to the
little horn power of daniel chapter
seven so we should have no problem as to
who we are dealing with
correct also she sits on seven hills
which is a pretty
descriptive a very a very sharp clue
right
and we will drop down
to the time when she has passed the east
east stage the is not stage and there is
to come stage right
and we actually read that in
verse 10
where it says
and there are seven kings five are
fallen one is and the other is not yet
and when he has come
he must continue a short space we're not
going to go into that bible study as to
exactly what that sequence is there are
other studies about that
but in verse 11 it says and the beast
political system
that was
and is not
even he is the eighth and he is of the
seven and goes into perdition it's a
very short
description of its entire history
it was
a beast power
in other words it wielded political
power over the kings of the earth
it went into a is not stage when it had
a mortal wound then it ascended out of
that deathly bottomless pit
and went to make war
against god's word
and against god's people as we read in
chapter 12 and particularly the remnant
yes the message is then mentioned
and then we can follow the rest
on the screen
just to set the stage for
what is happening
so let's take it up from verse 12
and the ten horns which thou sourced
are ten kings
which have received no kingdom as yet
but receive power as kings one hour with
the beast
that's a very interesting verse
because if they have received no power
as yet
that means
that they
have some power otherwise they wouldn't
be kings
but they're not wielding that power
together with the beast
and only when you are in total harmony
with the beast do you have
legitimized power
remember we spoke about jehu that's it
who wore the phrygian cap
he was subject to salmonella
and he had power to rule
together with solmanizer
as an independent free spirit
subject to certain rules and regulations
all right so the ten horns
now we know that the european powers
were known as ten horns and we discussed
before
that whether we are dealing here with
ten horns and
all of the nations that arose out of
them
or whether we are dealing with the
division of the world into 10 regions is
irrelevant
it's a symbol of the whole world
that will rule together for one hour
with the beast
now whether that is a prophetic time or
whether it is
a mention of a particular short time
period
which is sometimes the case in the bible
is not really of such great consequence
the fact of the matter is
that the ten horns will receive power as
kings one hour with the beast
and in order to do that
they must adopt the philosophy of the
beast
correct yes
so they will also have to have the same
mindset
that's exactly what the next verse says
if you look at revelation chapter 17
verse 13 it says they have one mind
in other words they have been well
indoctrinated
during
the movements in darkness
and then what will they do
they shall give their power and strength
unto the beast
so this is quite clear there from this
statement that they had power they
wielded secular power
but true power
according to the beast
is only there
when
the secular sword is combined
with the religious sword
then you have true power
because then you also control
worship yes
the book of revelation is about worship
in fact the whole bible is about worship
correct who is the authority who is the
authority
so they will have one mind and they
shall give their power and strength unto
the beast in other words
they will use the power of the state to
enforce the dictates of the beast
and
this beast power
makes it look like it's god's will
yes but in actual fact it's
her will which in actual fact is the
dragon's will because the dragon gave
her a seat and power and great authority
now what will they do martin once they
have given their strength and power unto
the beast this is very very scary
they shall make war with the lamb
and the lamb shall overcome them for his
lord of lords and king of kings and they
that are with him are called and chosen
and faithful so who does he war against
god's people yeah and in
the fact that they're warring against
god's people they're warring against
jesus
and against his word
and he says unto me the waters which
they are sourced where the horse sitteth
are peoples and multitudes and nations
and tongues
now martin when you sit
you rule
they sat in moses's seat jesus said
referring to the pharisees
in other words they ruled over the
people
so when you sit when pilate went into
the praetorium to cast judgment he
sat
so where does this ruling power sit well
it sits amongst the peoples the
multitudes the nations and the tongues
she's a universal power
whether we see her or not is irrelevant
she's there exactly according to this
the bible says so
and the ten horns which they are sourced
upon the beast
these shall hate the [__]
and shall make her desolate and naked
and shall eat her flesh and burn her
with fire now it's very fascinating
martin because just prior to this
they were of one mind and gave their
power unto the beast
so then they were
they were united in opposition to whom
to christ and his people
and they will be overcome in other words
they will realize that they have been
duped when they are overcome because
obviously the beast promised them
victory right
but they will realize that they have
been duped and there must come a change
in attitude
unfortunately that change in attitude is
too late for them yes because probation
has closed it comes after the close of
probation
so those ten horns which they are
sourced upon the beast the ones that
gave their power unto the beast
shall then
turn upon her they shall hate her
and shall make her desolate and naked
and shall eat her flesh and burn her
with fire
that's fascinating
now the punishment for prostitution in
the old testament was stoning yes
unless it was the daughter of a priest
then it was burning with fire so this
tells us that this [__] is a
priestly associate
she is the priest of someone
she is the daughter of someone namely
the dragon
jesus said you either have
god is your father
or you have the devil as your father
because jesus said to
the pharisees you are of your father the
devil
so she is the daughter of that father
and she will be burnt with fire that's
actually a synopsis of the entire end
time happenings
why for god has put it into their hearts
to fulfill his will again here we are
speaking about god's permissive will
and to agree and give their kingdom unto
the beast
god is permitting this in other words
god is permitting
what we are going to talk about today
in this episode
god is permitting it
now we can scream and shout as much as
we like this is the devil's plan that's
it but god is permitting it
why is he permitting it
so that his whole plan and to show him
as
the true
god as lord of lord and king of kings
and in to enable people to make a
informed decision so that you cannot
turn back and say but i did not know
exactly so this must be very prominent
so god permits it
and to agree and give their kingdom unto
the beast until the words of god shall
be fulfilled
can i therefore conclude martin
that when the kings had not yet given
their power unto the beast this was far
more in line with god's will
than giving their power unto them
definitely and it's also those words
until the words of god shall be
fulfilled
he
said this would happen
and it's prophetically there yes
so in the end you cannot bleed ignorance
you know this is so fascinating so
martin when you look at this and it says
until
the words of god shall be fulfilled
in other words prophecy will come
to fruition right
now
we've been talking about this for years
and those that are opposed to this
philosophy this biblical picture
will shout conspiracy theory and they've
been shouting conspiracy theory and
writing conspiracy theory at nausea
i'm wondering what they will say
when the conspiracy turns out to be
facts checked
by
by the biblical criteria the highest
authority and turns out to be true
then they cannot claim sorry we were
wrong will they be weeping and wailing
and gnashing of teeth
and the woman which thou sourced is that
great city
martin there's only one
church
that is called a city even by in their
own ranks
and that is the church of rome
which reigneth over the kings of the
earth
so even if it doesn't appear as if she
is reigning at the moment because the
power has not yet been given unto her
she reigns exactly
they are all doing
her bidding they are doing her betting
this is the prophetic picture
and whether we like it or not
is how it is because god said so
therefore
it is so and you cannot get away from it
so now with that brief introduction
shall we
jump into where we are in the stream of
time please
here's the national catholic reporter
from march 29 2022
why the economy of francesco
can develop a new economics and create a
better world
but just that title
in itself
are they creating a kingdom
in this world on earth right now what
does the bible say about the kingdom of
this world it will be destroyed there
will be nothing left but dust and ashes
and if you are a friend of it you will
be destroyed with it because you are an
enemy with god of god by your own
choosing by your own choosing so just
that title alone by the national
catholic reporter
will tell you is a serious problem
because it's in direct opposition to
what the bible is saying so how does
this better world according to them
look like
the francesco here is the pope's
namesake saint francis of assisi the
idea is to develop a new economics
for the 21st century one that responds
to the challenges of our time
christians jews muslims buddhists hindus
confucianists indigenous leaders secular
philosophers
stop there
what did we just read
she is the mother of
harlots hollis and what was the harlot
again that that is against god it's an
apostate system okay
all right secular philosophers have
found time and again that there are
common perspectives on how to proceed
for the global common interests
common good
we strongly recommend the great joy of
delving into the church's social
teachings starting with the pope's
recent encyclicals
the young people in assisi and our own
students around the world heartily agree
it's not all that often that one gets to
engage intensively with the thoughts of
aristotle
jesus thomas aquinas
francis of assisi the commenial
patriarch batholmew of constantinople
the grand imam sheikh ahmed el-tayeb of
al-azhar university and pope francis
martin
if you have aristotle there and jesus in
the same sentence is there harmony or is
there
there's a big conflict conflict that
cannot be
you cannot put those two in the same
uh on the same level okay now if you
want to put jesus into that category
together with thomas aquinas who says
there's no sin
if the poor take that which belongs to
someone else
because it doesn't really belong to them
even if the commandment says thou shalt
not covet thy neighbor's good see thomas
aquinas who is a according to them a
saint says that stealing is perfectly
fine under those circumstances
and jesus said if you want to have life
keep the commandments so we have we have
a dichotomy here right
and to throw aristotle into the mix is
is just absolutely amazing
so this jesus
cannot be jesus of nazareth right no
this must be another jesus yes could
this be barabas yes
that's it we'll talk about that at
another stage but also interesting
you see
the basis that they want to say this new
economy has can bring together is built
on the recent encyclicals of the pope
correct which was and you read it in
here
the fraterna fratelli tutti that's the
fraternity the brotherly love and ladau
to see yes that's on the environment and
all of this
yeah
that's how this whole thing gets
together now when we read then chapter
we read about the two aspects of this
power she's a beast she's a political
system right
but she's also a harlot yes she in fact
she's the mother of the harlots that's
the religious system right that's it so
this here seems to me
to be a pointer that the religious
system
is entirely on board
that's it so the last final thing that
must happen
is that the political system must come
on board by giving their power unto the
beast
that's what we're waiting for
the first one has already been fulfilled
now a couple of years ago who would
imagine that that could be fulfilled by
now i don't even think you have to go
far back about three years ago this
wasn't that clear it wasn't that clear
ryan and when i was married as i said
many times before
my wife's family didn't attend the
wedding because i was
of uh
the beast
power
so the church's social teachings make it
possible for everybody to join in this
2000 year year-old conversation
this conversation can be a springboard
for a better world
that is the true goal of the economy of
francisco
so this utopia that he's talking about
is actually the great nightmare
that will bring about
that situation where the kings of the
world will actually start hating her and
will destroy her that's it a time such
as never was of trouble but we'll be
caught in the middle right
but once they've given their power unto
the beast they're going to make war with
god's people yeah
so we must be
on the verge of that event right on that
knife's edge okay
now how do you create a great crisis
one of the things you do is you
introduce a food crisis yeah and that's
also a result of this war
okay so you need to have a precedent
in order to explain the food crisis
now they're talking about climate change
but crops still keep coming in in spite
of their arguments in favor of their
climate change theories right yes
although as we've discussed many times
the facts and the philosophy just don't
seem to gel
so we need another crisis so how about a
supply line crisis
how do you affect
the food crisis well you introduce
another calamity another form of chaos
out of which you then create the order
that you want
i mean if we go into the pandemic that
already started
this food crisis yes supply lines and
even production yes
well here's a nice discussion that took
place on weon
and uh it's interesting that this
channel was banned for a while and then
resurfaced
yes youtube banned them and then there
was such an outcry that within 12 hours
the channel was reinstated on youtube
well let's let's hear what they have to
say
this war ladies and gentlemen is
bleeding all of us
do you have a car at home
what does it run on oil or gas i'm
guessing
taking that car out will become more
expensive courtesy the war in ukraine
you see nearly 12 of the world's oil
comes from russia it is among the three
top players in the oil market and this
country is now at war how expensive
exactly let's talk about india the
reserve bank of india says every 10 rise
in crude prices adds about 0.5 to
inflation basically the devastation of
ukraine means inflation for you this war
has disrupted the global supply chain of
sunflower oil and soon kitchens around
the world will be suffering once again
take india for example more than 70
percent of india's sunflower oil is
imported
000 tons of sunflower oil shipments from
the black sea region to india are stuck
reports also say the prices of edible
oil could go up within weeks meaning
cooking at home will be more expensive
ordering in will also be more expensive
ukraine also supplies corn in fact it is
one of the world's top five corn
exporters in 2019 ukraine traded
35.9 million metric tons of corn russia
2 is a big player together with ukraine
it accounts for 19 percent of the
world's corn supplies this war will have
a ripple effect on the cost of corn
syrup corn flakes even popcorn
ukraine by the way is china's biggest
corn supplier then there is wheat russia
is the world's largest exporter of wheat
it accounts for 20 percent of the global
exports ukraine supplies 10 percent of
global wheat in 2021 70 of russia's
wheat
went to west asia and africa
this region will soon have to pay more
for flour pasta pita bread pizza
basically every wheat based product
well so we have a food crisis and every
nation on earth is talking about a food
crisis and we have an energy crisis
now isn't it interesting
that not so long ago
in fact under the trump
era
america was totally independent in terms
of its oil needs and these were
immediately shut down when the new
administration took over it's almost
like
a preparation for a crisis it was almost
as if they were preparing for a plan
yes
and
food supplies so you need something very
specific
because food supply
cannot be explained just from exports
from russia and ukraine
there are other nations that can take up
the slack the united states is a massive
grain producer
many countries have the capacity to
produce grains so there must be some
other factor
and that of course was fertilizer
because one of the components in
fertilizer apparently is largely from
russia
so that affects farming
worldwide
so in other words what they are saying
is there's no such thing as an
independent country
everything is interdependent interlinked
if
one sneezes here this one catches a gold
all right now how long have they been
planning that
for decades that is you see this is all
part of the
old world order yes
if you take
the situation just in our own country
how the laws changed many years ago as
to what was permitted to be grown in
terms of let's say anything wood for
example
no this had to come from that region or
grain this kind of grain no we're not
going to concentrate on that anymore
another country australia is going to do
this and we're going to do that we're
not going to make our own steel we're
going to export the iron and import the
steel then we're interdependent we're
not
independent you see that was part of the
industrial revolution then yes they
cooked up this whole
scenario so that when they want to
implant this new one this whole thing is
already in place so they made the world
so interdependent
that you cannot remove a cog out of the
wheel without destroying the machine
that's what they did right
there may never again be a time
when a nation is
self-sufficient that was the plan
now we have to introduce a crisis
because nations cling to sovereignty
that sovereignty has to go the power
must be granted unto the beast and then
you will have a centralized power so
first you must have pain so that you can
produce the gain
all right so we see
that uh these things are already biting
they're already part of
the social fabric
spain allows supermarket rationing to
prevent shortages spanish supermarkets
can legally ration consumer purchases
of certain products under a new
provision published wednesday in the
state's official bulletin
the text which provides legal cover says
the restrictions can be applied
exceptionally and when there are
extraordinary circumstances
or false measures
that justify it
spain has been struggling with a wave of
social unrest over runaway inflation and
rising prices with lorry driver striking
production stoppages mass protests by
farmers and fishermen
soaring energy prices have also driven
spain's inflation rate to a 37 year high
jumping to 9.8
in march up from 7.6
in february what is this a spanish
problem
no it's actually a worldwide problem yes
it doesn't matter which country you're
looking at it's interesting
like you just said previously
there's still pain with us
yes this you know the pain to they must
we were still and some of them get to
the gain
well i don't think this could work if
you took uh
two pacific islands which were at war
for example
you needed the super powers to come into
conflict with each other or potentially
to come into conflict with each other in
order to
make this thing work and
using the pandemic where there were
already
these types of rationing going on
people have been getting used to this
almost yes they have been conditioned
now there's another factor here
when you start introducing shortages
then you have panic situations
now what if you can use these shortages
to also control behavior
that's what's going to happen
so is it possible martin that you could
link these things in such a way
that you can control social behavior
that's
definitely where everything is heading
all right so
one of the things that you'd have to
test
is civil obedience
that's it so you need to create some
situation where you can test the
willingness
of a citizen to comply with certain
civil obedience issues
and i think they introduced one during
the pandemic
and they introduced a certificate
which gives you economic access or
exclusion according to your choice
you better
be in harmony with the beast
or else you still have your choice
but if you're not in harmony with it you
exclude yourself they're not excluding
you the devil justifies that choice
martin because god does a very similar
thing
god says you either comply with my
commandments
or you will be eliminated
so he's trying the same thing he's
saying you either comply with my
commandments or you will be eliminated
he's got one shortcoming
his elimination is temporary
god's elimination is permanent imminent
time tells us
the war in ukraine is creating the
greatest global food crisis since world
war ii the u.n says so it's not a
spanish issue
it's not a united kingdom issue it is a
universal issue
the un food chief warned tuesday the war
in ukraine has created a catastrophe
on top of a catastrophe and will have a
global impact
beyond anything we've seen since world
war ii because many of the ukrainian
farmers who produce a significant amount
of the world's wheat are now fighting
russians
so the ukrainian grain will be gone and
all nations
will be affected
even nations that grow their own wheat
or
own grain yes
absolutely even those
maybe they will have to export it to
nations that are totally dependent on
ukrainian grain
so martin if you then on top of it
make it impossible in terms of
availability and price
to
fertilize your lands
would that add to the food crisis oh
definitely because then even the ones
that produce it themselves have a
problem so this is a perfect conflict
we don't have to read at all the war in
ukraine is turning the bread basket of
the world to breadlines
now martin the bread basket of the world
in historic terms
wasn't necessary the ukraine but more
the united states and some
eastern countries such as china etc
but at least they qualified by saying
that it was for millions of the world's
people
while devastating countries like egypt
that normally gets 85 percent of its
grain from ukraine and lebanon
that got 81
in 2020 beasley said
ukraine and russia produce 30 percent of
the world's wheat supply 20 percent of
its corn 75 to 80 percent of the
sunflower seed oil
and the world food program buys 50 of
its grain from
ukraine
he said
this is
major so
where are the other countries that
produce these things
now martin i i don't want to question
these these statistics that are being
given here
but i've been around on this in this
world for a few years
and
this is not how i learned
my history
if you take for example the southern
african situation
zimbabwe was the bread basket of africa
it produced
massive amount of corn and south africa
was a massive producer exporting
many many of its commodities
and if we look at those economies and
what happened particularly in zimbabwe
then
that situation has been removed i wonder
whether
looking back and trying to fit it into
this picture
whether it was necessary to remove some
of the bread baskets
wasn't it interesting that farmers in
particularly were targeted in zimbabwe
for example yes
to get everybody dependent
on something else yes it seems as if
farmers
are a target for
many of the social actions that are
taking place in the world today
well let's hear
what president biden has to say on the
issue
with regard to food shortage yes we did
we
still talk about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real the the
price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries in our country as
well
and uh because both
russia and ukraine have been the
breadbasket of europe in terms of wheat
for example just give one example how
high do you think oil prices can get at
the pump
uh listen i
there's a lot of uncertainty about it
they're not as high in real terms as
they were
earlier earlier in this century and
they you know it's conceivable that they
could move higher
mike gunderson's family has been farming
wheat soybeans and corn on this land
since the 1950s he expects the weather
to throw him a curveball and farming but
not a war
all the stuff in ukraine and there's so
much volatility in the market the u.s
imports 10.3 billion dollars worth of
fertilizer for crops 1.3 billion of that
comes from russia which is now off the
market the minnesota association of
wheat growers says farmers lay down
fertilizer at least twice a year there's
a lot of fertilizers that are four and
five x more expensive than they were
a year ago fertilizer has drastically
outpaced the rate of inflation russia's
ban on fertilizer is scheduled to last
until the end of the year and while
supply is already tight this year it's
the future many are worried about
gas prices are jacking up the cost of
boat rentals and charters
leaving captains like cody kinney with
two choices cancel charters that are not
profitable or increase ticket prices the
increases are not just hitting the
tourism industry from our boats that go
out fishing to our trucks that deliver
the product everything that we use to
run our business
we see at least a 35 percent increase
nello cassarino runs galveston shrimp
company he says passing those prices
onto the consumer is not a reliable
option because the consumer at some
point will stop buying it it turns into
a
ripple effect where the plants have to
lay off employees
you know trucks stop moving
well they're pushing the food shortage
agenda and a few weeks ago or months
we heard similar stories in our own
country and warnings to
in this regard
and we also had a last year situation of
social unrest correct and how that
affected supplies and everything in our
country so there seems to be a war
on distribution and supply lines
there's an article in the hill biden
warns of real food shortage risk over
russia's invasion into ukraine
and uh what did he say we did talk about
food shortages and it's going to be real
the price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries and our own country
as well we just heard him say that right
biden said at a press conference from
brussels where he's meeting with nato
leaders
senior administration officials warned
that russia's invasion threatens to
jeopardize food security for the middle
east and africa in particular
now martin i
tried to buy fertilizer in our own
country the other day just to see what
the situation was about
it was virtually unobtainable
there had been mass buying by farmers
and now there was none
and particularly some of the components
in
the fertilizer they say
came from russia therefore fertilizer
would not be available so this is a is a
recipe for food shortages
and the bible
does it say there will be food shortages
it says
famines
pestilences
and all of these things will be
near the end
but the big sign is
that they will give their power unto the
beast right
we'd rate that
and once they have done that the very
next step
is war
against
god's people
against jesus and his truth
that also tells me that everybody that
will eventually now you've got all this
chaos and everybody is in a frenzy
but they will stand together because
they have a common enemy
when they go against god's people they
will try to find a common enemy and it
must be on the basis of some religious
aspect which they have clearly connected
with their agenda
so martin the bible also tells us
that one of the mechanisms to introduce
this wall
will be to make it impossible for those
who do not
follow the dictates of the beast to buy
or sell
so we need a restructuring of the
world's financial system in order to
achieve that
so a new world order also requires a new
financial
system this is conspiracy theories
well so they said
and i'm wondering whether those that
claimed that it was
conspiracy theories were practicing
ostrich
philosophy having their heads stuck in
the sand
so let's hear some of the talk on this
issue in the world
here
president biden is addressing a
roundtable discussion with leading
businesses all right let's see what he
has to say
they're also suggesting that ukraine has
biological and chemical weapons in
ukraine
that's a clear sign he's considering
using both of those he's already used
chemical weapons in the past and we
should be careful about what's about to
come he knows there'll be severe
consequences because of the united nato
front but the point is it's real and
what i want to mention very much
very very quickly with you all is
one of the tools he's most likely to use
in my view in our view
is a cyber cyber attacks they have a
very sophisticated cyber capability
but uh look today my administration
issuing new warnings
that based on evolving intelligence
russia may be planning a cyber attack
against us
as i said the magnitude of russia's
cyber capacity is fairly consequential
and it's coming the federal government
is doing its part to get ready
but under u.s law as you all remember
the private sector all of you
largely decides the protections that is
you will or will not take
in order to protect your sources
but let me be absolutely clear about
something it's not just in your interest
or at stake whether potential use of
cyber security it is the national
interest at stake
and i would respectfully suggest it's a
patriotic obligation for you to invest
as much as you can and making sure and
we will heard will help in any way that
you have built up your technological
capacity to deal with cyber capacity
with cyber attacks
first
to protect your own companies second
that provides critical
as you as providers of critical services
that america's
rely on from power to clean water
and finally your role you can play in
helping secure every american
and
every american's
privacy for example
banks can turn on cyber security by
default
for every customer so america's
financial data is safe
and we're prepared to help you as i said
with any tools and expertise we possess
if you're ready to do that
but it's your decision as to the steps
you'll take and your responsibility to
take them not ours
you know we are at an inflection point i
believe in the world economy not just
the world economy in the world it occurs
every three or four generations
as one of them as the one of the top
military people said to me in a secure
meeting the other day
60 60 million people died between 1900
and 1946
and uh since then we established a
liberal world order and that hadn't
happened in a long while a lot of people
dying but nowhere near the chaos
and now is the time when things are
shifting we're gonna they're gonna be a
new world order out there and we've
gotta lead it we've gotta unite the rest
of the free world and doing it
did he say there was going to be a new
world order and they have to lead it he
even said that there has been a new
world a world order
since its second world war yes
so this has been introduced
incrementally
so every crisis has been used to
introduce something new
and they certainly will not let this
good crisis go by
without using it to the full
he also said
there will be a cyber attack yes
did klaus schwab say that exactly the
same
and did they have training sessions as
to how to deal with it yes
just like they had training scenarios
for the pandemic
and it
materialized now what is interesting he
said you will have to prepare
we will help you but we won't take
responsibility yes it's not their job so
when they crash the system do they have
a scapegoat yes yes everybody is the
scapegoat except them right
so
i i was in a chat today with someone and
i hear that the minister announced
that a new variant is on the way
and that it will be here pretty soon
he declined to give the exact date when
it would arrive or by which train
but
and exactly what time
but if we have the same thing over here
there is something that is coming they
decline to give the exact time or the
exact date
but it will come it will you see we've
already
seen
some of this
cyber attacks
pop up
all right we've had one in south africa
for instance
one of the major record-keeping
companies in south africa had a cyber
breach
and then they sent out emails
to tell you that
some of your data can be
used by these people to do identity
theft so you are compromised yes now
when this happens now imagine
putting this all together
so you have a food crisis
you have a production crisis when it
comes to food and you have a supply line
crisis
and we've seen that cyber attacks have
been used to create supply line crisis
there was
attacks in the united states on the oil
supply lines
they could attack the
electricity grid
and now he warned that they could attack
the banking system that means if there
was a cyber attack you would have no
access to money that would create a fair
amount of chaos
and
we're we're building up a
recipe for chaos here
and out of this chaos must emerge a new
world order never again
may it be allowed that countries that
are so interconnected go to war with
each other
they are of one mind
and they give their power unto the peace
my personal opinion
is that they are playing this game
according to a very well
contrived script
the art of war
yes
now here's an article from forbes russia
and china are leading a new world order
russian foreign minister says
a wednesday meeting in china between
russia and china's foreign minister
amplified china's continued signs of
coursing up to russia
amid its invasion of ukraine
key facts
chinese foreign minister wang yi and
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
met wednesday in tungsten china marking
lavrov's second trip abroad since russia
invaded ukraine
on february the 24th china and russia
are moving towards creating a new just
and democratic world order
doesn't that sound like a social justice
issue from the pen of francesco that's
it
lavrov said in a video released by
russian ministry of foreign affairs
wednesday and translated by afp
a photograph tweeted by the russian
ministry of foreign affairs showed
lavrov and wem bumping elbows
and including the russia chinese hashtag
followed by a handshake emoji
further emphasizing the country's
collaboration wang shared lover of signs
of encouragement and said he left the
meeting more determined
to boost the relationship between china
and russia according to reuters so here
you have this recipe for world conflict
all the more reason to bring them all
together right this fraternity that has
to happen yes because
there's nobody who will win
in this kind of war especially if it
goes nuclear
algeria zera asked the question is the
war in ukraine ushering in a new world
order
as the fighting in ukraine escalates the
war is shaping how global powers
confront future threats and conflicts
the new war in europe has been described
as a turning point in human history
it's been more than a month since russia
invaded ukraine causing death and
destruction across much of the country
the invasion and the political disputes
around us
are disrupting a global order that has
been in place since the end of the cold
war
isn't that what biden said that there
was going to be a shift which comes
every so many generations
and every time that somebody said there
was a world order after the second world
war they were conspiracy theorists yes
the conflict is also defining how
democracies will confront future threats
and conflicts
but what will the foundations of the new
order be
and will western values still prevail
well martin
the ten kings will give their power unto
the beast so
western morality will prevail as long as
it is papal morality
so instead of us talking so much because
people will say we are sprouting
conspiracy theories let the powers that
be
speak for themselves
here's another video world government
summit
youtube channel
and of course the world economic forum
is very much associated with this
particular event let's have a look
a very very good morning on what is the
first official day of world government
summit here at dubai expo 2020 and the
title
of this session
are we ready for a new
world order
and just as the world
reemerges from the pandemic we are faced
with the russian invasion of ukraine
which certainly feels like a
transformative geopolitical moment
is the us-led multilateral system
created post-world war ii
to manage
international relations
so that the world would never again see
and experience the same chaos and
disorder of a
world war
is it anything like
fit for purpose
and if not
what is
the alternative
your excellency
are you
ready
for a new world order the frame of
thinking is still 19th century i think
this is one of the problems that we have
in the international system it's still
about nationalism it's still about state
sovereignty it's still about use of
force or non-use of source of force and
i think this is one of the major major
issues and i think where we are now and
this gets to your question becky of a
new world order
is uh
it can go in two directions with the war
in ukraine now being a decisive element
either the jungle is back as the
historian bob kagan talks
and and that we can go into a darker era
or we could go into an era because of
the advances of science advances
technology that could be one of the most
prosperous promising progressive
enlightened moderate modern eras that
we've ever faced and i think we're in a
moment where that's being decided and i
think the importance of the ukraine
issue
is that it's a fulcrum for this and how
the world manages this and comes out of
this is going to have far reaching
consequences that go beyond ukraine
that's not about the us versus china
it's about what underpins a world order
is always the financial system
i was very privileged my father was an
advisor to nixon when they came off the
gold standard in 71 and so i was brought
up with a kind of inside view of how
very important the financial structure
is to absolutely everything else
and what we're seeing in the world today
i think is we are on the brink of a
dramatic change where we are about to
and i'll say this boldly we're about to
abandon the traditional system of money
and accounting
and introduce a new one and the new one
the new accounting is what we call
blockchain
it means digital it means having a
almost perfect record of every single
transaction that happens in the economy
which will give us far greater clarity
over what's going on it also raises huge
dangers in terms of the balance of power
between states and citizens in my
opinion we're going to need a digital
constitution of human rights if we're
going to have digital money uh but also
this new money will be
sovereign in nature most people think
that digital money is crypto and private
but what i see are super powers
introducing digital currency the chinese
were the first
the u.s is on the brink i think of
moving in the same direction the
europeans have committed to that as well
and the question is will that new system
of digital money and digital accounting
accommodate the competing needs of the
citizens of all these locations so that
every human being has a chance to have a
better life because that's the only
measure of whether a world order really
serves when we ask what is the new world
order going to look like
the answer is so much depends on how we
handle what's happening now which we
can't even agree upon just one last
thing because it's so essential to this
region
is the extraordinary hit
to the supply chain of food
and i think we cannot leave this event
without speaking about the need to
prepare now
to prevent a catastrophe because the
loss of the fertilizers from both russia
and belarus
the enormous increase in the oil price
which directly hits farmers around the
world
already has caused a jump in the wheat
price which is the single most important
food stuff for this region and last time
we saw this
that was a major contributing factor to
the arab spring so now is the time to
think through how will we solve this
and that will be part of the answer of
what will the new order work like
martin there were a number of
factors that were mentioned there
the first speaker spoke about
nationalism
sovereignty sovereignty that that would
have to go
the second speaker sounded like a modern
kissinger
he actually said that that's his mentor
martin kessinger and kissinger was his
mentor and of course kissinger was very
pro new world order
so he basically emphasized the fact that
it is essential that we get this new
world order
and then the ladies spoke about the
financial system
but that it wouldn't be like the current
cryptocurrency no no
because it would
not be incognito
you would be totally transparent
and there would be certain control
systems so that you have
absolute knowledge of what's happening
in the economy
martin can i ask a question
would you also have absolute knowledge
as who is partaking in the economy 100
would you have to have a system in place
that can exclude people
so when they said that china had already
introduced it
were they perhaps referring to the fact
that
china has certain conditions attached to
their
economic
accessibility that's it the social
credit system
and it's linked also to surveillance and
all of this it's nothing is uncoupled
imagine when you look at all of these
factors
can you see the biblical
paradigm
being enacted before your eyes it's
clear i think that the glass is getting
a little bit clear
so let's look at another one which is
very fascinating
so in this in this video the stansberry
research youtube channel she refers to a
document from the fed
where they are speaking about
introducing this kind of world currency
right yeah they want to do a digital
dollar yes so that's exactly what the
previous lady had referred to
and now we're just
putting the facts together and seeing
that this is not conspiracy this is
actually happening
if we would have played this video
before the one that we have already
played then you would have said it's
conspiracy but now you've heard it from
the horse's mouth
so that's how you can know that what
you'll see now how this fits in there in
other words you have to put the horse in
front of the cart
because when you put the cart in front
of the horse because you have knowledge
about the cart or insight then people
will shout conspiracy theory all right
i think you you did well by putting them
into the sequence martin
the federal reserve needs to be
preparing for the payment landscape of
the future even as we continue to make
improvements to meet today's needs in
light of the rapid
digitalization of the financial system
the fed has been thinking critically
about whether there is a role for a
potential u.s central bank digital
currency so
all roads seem to be pointing to the
coming digital currency the question is
how are they going to get people's
buy-in for this
oh well that's quite easy if you uh
advise people
as a government to go to the app store
and download the fat wallet and you tell
people there will be ten dollars on the
fat wallet
once you downloaded it everybody will
jump on it and actually in ukraine we
have seen something like this this
there was the start last month of an
e-wallet in which the government advised
people you can download this e-wallet
and you can get subsidies
but only if you're vaccinated so you see
this merger of uh
well uh e-money
electronic money digital money but only
if you well behave so this reminds me on
the china system where the credit score
is uh well it is used in a way to
take away part of your freedom if you
don't behave well and this this is what
can happen now in the west as well
does modern monetary theory have to go
digital well it helps
it helps because
you will have
money which is highly programmable so
you can
say to people you you have to spend this
money before the end of the year because
otherwise it will
well it won't be there on your wallet
anymore you can
[Music]
tell people where they
should spend it on so you can can't
spend on holidays but you can spend it
on energy and food and i think this is
something which uh authorities
they love it because they will get more
control over their people and they can
follow each and every payment and you
you leave traces everywhere
so in tandem you know with going digital
is the push to get to zero net uh
emissions by you know 20 50. can you
talk a little bit yes sorry
it will all be connected uh because
um they will know exactly once we have
this fully digital payment system and we
all have this e-wallet they know exactly
what you buy they know exactly where you
go and they will
they will calculate your your co2
footprint
and when you um when you have buy too
many airline tickets you will be
punished in a way and
um so it it will all be connected so
they will tell you it is all needed to
fight climate change there will be the
spin but it's it's all about control and
it's all about maintaining
the current uh dollar-centered world
reserve system and of course there's a
lot of st there's a lot at stake here
from a un secretary general antonio
guterres who says
top five things we should be fighting
for around the world right now
number one
fighting covet
transforming the global financial system
what does that involve willem
we need to change
the international monetary system we
need to move it to the next phase i call
this a monetary reset
he wants to organize a new bretton woods
conference
with the leading 20 companies
countries around the world
and this reminds me of the imf which
published
this new website or part of their
website in october 2020 calling for a
new bretton woods moment but not telling
us what this was all about
and it also reminded me about a speech
given by
janet jelen or it might have been an
interview
and the treasury secretary said
we should be prepared to build a new
global economy from the ground up in a
new restructured world
and then we had this speech by mark
carney and jackson hall in what was it
july august 2019 and he called for a
global monetary system to replace the
dollar according to the financial times
and this speech is still on the website
of the bank of england he was the
governor of the bank of england he's
retired now
and he also said mark carney there will
be a change in this unsustainable
monetary system
and and i follow many of his speeches
because he is on the forefront of this
movement and he had another speech in
2020 in which he said the world needs a
new sustainable financial system to stop
runaway climate change
martin there is not much that we can add
to that right
what we may add is we told you so
because this is what we've been saying
for a long time all right let's just
summarize
we have a system where we're going to go
digital
that system is totally monitored
there is the
likelihood
or the absolute certainty if i may say
so if we
invoke the bible
of a social credit system
that you will be forced to comply with
certain conditions
climate change will be one of them
climate change as we've said in previous
ones is linked to a religious scenario
as well it's like the glue and it's
linked to the mark of the beast
everything is linked to that thing and
therefore we have the complete scenario
to
see the implementation
of
the biblical prophecy for the time of
the end
the conflict between the precepts of
christ
and the kings of the world because they
will make war against the lamb and
against his people
so it's the clash of two mindsets
now one thing that's very interesting to
me
if you were to confront the world
and say to them
we're going to introduce a new
currency
where we will determine what you may buy
when you may buy how you may buy and
even if you may buy
would you have riots in the world oh
definitely would you have
civil descent in the world
you would have chaos right
so to introduce it like that would be
totally counterproductive what if you
did it the other way around martin
what if you introduced a
total collapse of the economy perhaps
use
hypothetically speaking
a pandemic
to collapse certain economic situations
and then introduce a war
to collapse other infrastructures and
supply supply lines
and then
uh hypothetically of course introduce a
cyber attack
that destroys
companies maybe destroys banking systems
maybe destroys the people's lives
and livelihoods
and introduce famine and
total
financial collapse
then in order to
get over this calamity
step in as the hero
and you introduce a
basic
income that's it
for all of humanity
so as the man said download a e-wallet
for that you would have to restore
certain cyber activity of course
then you introduce an e-wallet and
there's money on it which you can access
provided you have complied to certain
conditions
right
so those conditions could be
health status con conditions or they
could be climate state conditions which
could be associated with the religious
conflicts worship yes with worship
and then you have access to this
e-wallet then they tell you
in order to safeguard your e-wallet
we have to determine what people
purchase from this and they mustn't be
able to steal it from you either because
it's really our philanthropic
activity to give you this e-wallet we
will introduce a digital system that
totally controls it so that you can feel
secure
then you will have introduced the chaos
and produced the solution if you had
done it the other way around
it would have been seen as an enemy and
you would have had chaos with no
solution yes now it's a friend
now it's a friend
and then you have the full scenario
for the fulfillment of prophecy
martin
and i also would like to add
there's nothing
that i think
anybody can do about it no it's going to
happen it's coming it's being prophesied
so for all the skeptics out there and
all those that over the years shouted
conspiracy theories
and for those that think that this has
nothing to do
with a religious system that the bible
calls the mother of harlots
i suggest we
wait till part two
of this discussion
shall we
close with the prayer absolutely
heavenly father
the table has been laid
the role players are sitting at the
table
and if we understand revelation and if
we understand daniel
then we must assume that all the role
players although they might appear to be
on opposite sides of the table are
actually sitting at the same table
and preparing for this final onslaught
against the lamb
and his people help us to stand strong
in jesus name amen amen
[Music]
you